today to Africa's live side-by-side one
rooted in the land the other urban and
growing at a frantic pace as cities
spread into the bush not all of Africa's
wild inhabitants take the hint to leave
to a Mozambique spitting cobra suburban
gardens are well watered hunting grounds
despite the humans and their pets it can
spray its venom up to 7 feet it's only
dangerous if it hits the eyes but it's
still a highly effective defense dr.
Roger Blaylock has spent many years
dealing with africa's venomous snakes he
has treated more than a thousand
snakebite victims without losing his
passion for keeping highly venomous
snakes at home
the puff adder is one of the most feared
snakes in Africa some believe it
delivers more bites than any other
species south of the Sahara but when
properly handled it can seem deceptively
passive this is a puff adder it's a
front hinge Fang sites you can see their
fangs along the upper Julie in fact I
can show them to you the puff adder
stores its fangs flat against the roof
of its mouth but when it's time for
action they unfold on tiny hinges the
fangs are hollow and inject their venom
like hypodermic needles now you can see
the venom in the bottom of the wineglass
there it's a yellow cover just a few
drops can kill a snake very similar to
this one about the same size and a puff
adder did in fact bite me on attempt and
over the next three days the the
swelling progressed had went up my arm
the bite wound actually bled
continuously for five days
the bottle is extremely painful at night
I was unable to sleep this part of my
thumb actually died and about two months
after the bite I had some of my left big
toe some of the meat and the skin
transplanted to it though I don't
recommend being bitten by these snakes
that's very painful and there must be
very few people who are able to pick
their noses with their big toe
you